I wanna bring your attention to a couple
of things here first we have the popular
health information website health line
which I think it's like 80 million
visitors a month or something along
those lines and it has a safe sex guide
which is supposed to guide you in the
ways of having safe sex but in that
guide it has introduced a new term which
is supposed to take the place of an old
term and I want to read a bit of this
guide to you okay this is what it said
these guides talking about other safe
sex guides these guides often
unnecessarily gender body parts as being
male parts and female parts and refer to
sex with women or sex with men excluding
those who identify as non-binary now
just a second here you notice how they
use the word gender as a verb this is
very common these days I hear people say
gender like it's a verb like it's
something that you do but it's not a
verb okay
gender is not a verb you can't gender
something it's not something that you
can do to a thing if you go out for the
day and you come home and somebody says
what were you doing today it wouldn't
make any sense for you to say oh I was
out gendering you know I was doing a bit
of gendering that's all just gender and
get a little gendering here little
gendering there that that doesn't make
any sense
it's not a verb stop it stop it many
individuals don't see body parts as
having a gender people have a gender
what
body parts don't have a gender because
people have a gender but people have
body parts don't they what does that
mean we're already really separating the
concept of a person from the concept of
body parts from the concept of gender so
those are three separate things so what
is a person then considered apart from
their body parts and their gender
well so what do you what is a person a
person is just like this abstract
concept floating in the ether is that is
that is that the idea of a person that
you have
it's like saying many people don't see
hair as having a color people have hair
color
anyway as a result going back to the gut
and as a result the notion that a penis
is exclusively a male body part and a
vulva is exclusively a female body part
is inaccurate oh that's how many people
see it is okay so that's that's how
people see it
all right people see it that way but if
people see it as the as people see the
earth is being flat well then I guess
the earth is flat right because people
see it that way
by using the word parts to talk about
genitals and using medical terms for
anatomy without attaching a gender to it
we become much more able to effectively
discuss safe sex in a way that's clear
and inclusive for the purposes of this
guide will refer to the vagina as the
front hole instead of solely using the
medical term vagina this is gender
inclusive language that's considerate of
the fact that some trans people don't
identify with the labels the medical
community attaches to their genitals
um well guess what I don't identify as
having arms I don't like that I don't I
don't think I have arms I've decided
that I don't have arms so don't call
them arms anymore you have to think of a
new word because I don't identify as
having arms so if I go to the doctor and
they say look at your arms I'm going to
be traumatized because what do you mean
I don't identify as having them right so
in that that's how this work now this
works now for example some trans and
non-binary identified people assigned
female at Birth may enjoy now let's stop
there for a second as I've said a
million times your sex is not assigned
to you now notice something here they
use the phrase assigned female so that's
they're not even usually they try to
draw this ridiculous distinction between
gender and sex you know like there's a
two different things but female is
definitely sex so what this medical
guide is claiming is that your sex it's
not just gender your sex your biological
sex is assigned to you by the doctor
after you are born that is what weird
that's what we're being told now bite
like you're your actual sex is something
that your doctor decides randomly
arbitrarily just yep that one's a girl
could it be that it could have been a
boy could have been a dragon could have
been a could have been the tooth fairy
but now we've decided to make it a girl
and anyway it goes on from there talking
about front wholes and so forth
now two quick things number one
I don't want to get overly graphic here
but front hole is not even an
anatomically correct description of the
body part that you have renamed that's
all I'll say
number two you really see the corseting
of the culture here that I am forced to
sit here in front of mixed company and
talk about front holes like that's not I
would prefer not to talk about these it
this should be and we are all all of us
we are way too comfortable having these
kinds of conversations with each other
where we're using words like front hole
and we're talking about you know these
sorts of things and that's what the
culture is done because when you've got
it's kind of like the choice that we
have is we can ignore this kind of stuff
and we cannon let that we can let this
insanity happen we're body parts are
being renamed in order to in order to
indulge the the fantasies of mentally
disordered individuals we can just let
that happen
and say fine and not acknowledge it or
we can engage with it and address it and
and oppose it but in doing so we're
forced to have these kinds of
conversations and I think that that
latter option is the correct option we
have to engage we have to we can't just
allow this this insanity to occur but it
it means necessarily that we all kind of
end up down in the muck and we're all
affected by the corseting of the culture
it's the same thing when you've got
people who are literally marching down
the street announcing their sex lives to
the entire world it's like hey everybody
guess what kind of sex we like to have
and we're proud of it when people are
doing that again there's the corseting
of the culture where we it's like we
don't want to know we'd rather not know
we'd rather not talk about but you are
shoving it in our face and now we're
forced to have this conversation which
is not even a conversation that we we
want to have with strangers in public
this is private stuff we shouldn't even
be talking about it but we're forced to
now the LGBT folks have been trying to
make front hole happen for a while now
and so I did I wrote a piece yesterday
where I suggested some other new words
to take the place of offensive body part
labels I mean if we're doing front
health and I suggested like lookee hole
for eyes smell stick for nose hearing
flaps for ears your mouth is now you're
talking side dangler forearms like I
said arms is offensive to me so call
them side danglers your fingers are your
pointy graspers okay they're not fingers
anymore your legs or your trunk stems
they're not legs and actually the entire
human body is now just a skin holder
it's not a body it's a skin holder and
you know we could go through we get
there many but every every part of the
human body is probably offensive to
someone so we could rename them all okay
let's table that story for a minute and
I want to go over and look at something
else that is seems to be completely
unrelated
here's another story after more than a
century behind bars
the beasts on boxes of animal crackers
are roaming free Mondelez international
parent company of Nabisco has redesigned
the packaging of its Barnum's animal
crackers after relenting the pressure
from People for the Ethical Treatment of
Animals PETA which has been protesting
the use of animals and circuses for more
than 30 years wrote a letter to the
company in the spring of 2016 calling
for a redesign given the egregious
cruelty inherent in circuses that use
animals and the public swelling
opposition to the exploitation of
animals used for entertainment we urged
Nabisco to update its packaging in order
to show animals who are free to roam in
their natural habitats what what PETA
wanted to do is they wanted to free the
caged animal crackers from their cages
and have the Box redesigned so that it's
not offensive anymore and the company
decided to actually go ahead and do that
so we've got those two things how are
they related
they're both hilarious for what but for
another they reveal something about
progressivism namely that progressivism
always progresses like a cancer you
can't say stay still it can't stay in
just one place
it cannot it can't camp out and defend
what it has gained it can't do that
it has to always march forward or in
whatever direction it's going we're
gotta really consider this to be forward
but wherever it's going it always has to
keep marching there it always has to
find new battles to fight new victories
and it's just this thing that's
constantly moving and what happens when
it has gotten to the point was it's
already won the culture it's already
achieved everything that it originally
set out to do what happens then well
then it's on to the animal crackers and
it's on to the front wholes it has to
move on to these ridiculous obscure
issues because it has already achieved
everything else that it wanted to
achieve this is the problem with any
movement once it gets where it's set out
to go
it doesn't know what to do with itself
and that goes back to the famous quote
about every cause begins as a movement
becomes a business degenerates into a
racket well progressivism is now it's
it's it's it's even it's worse than a
racket it's this it's this insane thing
that is barreling forward and just
consuming everything in its path path
progressivism is a movement more than
it's a philosophy it's a movement
because it moves it's always moves and
it simply wants to destroy what was old
what existed before and replace it with
something new the manipulation of
language is a perfect example of this
they want to get rid of old words and
replace them with new words for no other
reason than the fact that the new word
is new and the old one is old you notice
with this front whole thing they never
explained what what exactly even if I
were to accept the idea that the word
vagina is offensive to trans people and
therefore it has to be changed how is
front whole better what what actually
makes that less offensive
nothing does it's just a new term it's a
really dumb term it's crude it's crass
it's juvenile and I think even an even
just by saying front hole every time you
say front hole you lose 5 IQ points
that's what I've said it now 10 times
and then I've lost 50 IQ points by the
time I'm done doing this this this video
I'm gonna be I'm gonna be brain dead
laying just laying here because that's
how stupid it is but it's a new word and
that's what progressives do they just
take the old thing and put a new thing
in its place it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter if the new things and
improvement and it doesn't even matter
if the new thing actually addresses
whatever problems allegedly existed with
the old thing the new thing could have
the same problems but even worse but
it's put in place just because it's new
new is always better so we always need
new things all the old stuff has to be
tossed in the fire that is that is
that's what progressivism is doing just
barreling forward in whatever direction
it's going and destroying with whatever
it's in its path and replacing it with
new things and as progressivism moves
and moves and moves it gets further and
further away from anything that even
vaguely resembles truth or reason or
rationality and it descends further into
insanity and now it has descended all
the way into an animal cracker box and
it is finding reasons to fight over
animal crackers
that's what that's what happens and so
we can as conservatives
it's kind of a double-edged sword
because on one hand we can look at that
and we can say
we could point out that we can point out
to everyone else we'd say well look at
what progressivism it look look what
it's become look what kind of arguments
they're having look what look at what
kind of things they're fighting for now
look look at what they consider to be a
victory now renaming the vagina into the
frontal that's a that's a victory for
them and we could point that out to try
to guide people away from progressivism
and we should be because it works to our
benefit that progressivism has become so
completely utterly insane but on the
other hand
the only reason that they've gotten at
this point is that they exist they have
been so successful and that they've won
every other battle they they've
basically accomplished everything
everything that they wanted they got
every battle they fought they won and
that's how they've moved on to these
sorts of things
if you think about it they've they
already redefined human life through
abortion disqualifying all unborn
children from from having the the title
of human being that was an enormous
accomplishment that they achieved
decades ago they accomplished redefining
marriage which even 20 years ago was an
unthinkable thing but they've
accomplished that so they've been going
through and redefining tearing up
tearing out what was what was what was
old what was traditional tossing it in
the fire putting something new in its
place and they've done that with these
huge things and because they've already
achieved that now they can move on to
these really small crazy issues
so we should point to that and say look
you don't wanna be on that side you want
to be on the side of front holes and
fighting over animal crackers but at the
same time we should remember they only
got to this point because of our
failures as conservatives to defend
the definition of human life sanctity of
marriage and on and on and on all right
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed